you are a relationship expert so given
that this is the week that love island
is restarting in the uk i wanted to
speak to you about something that i
noticed online i thought was quite
interesting so there's a student news
publication called the tab
and they've got a trash page which is
kind of celebrity gossip and sort of
trashy news and stuff like that they put
a tweet out the other day that said the
love island promo pics are always so bad
so here's actually what the love island
is from 2022 look like in real life
so what they were saying is that the
promo pictures that are done by an
entire team a huge team right there's a
hair and makeup army there's stylists
there's professional lighting there's a
guy with a huge long lens dslr and it's
not like they just take one they take
tons and tons of photos on this photo
shoot
and they had a problem with the fact
that
those were unrepresentative and what
they were using is the benchmark for why
it was unrepresentative were their
instagram photos
so they went on and said look at them on
instagram and then look at what they're
doing so if you dig into the actual
article it says
there is one simple fact on this earth
and that is that the love island
photographer always does everyone so
dirty year after year it never changes
and the promo pics get if anything worse
so ahead of the launch next week of love
island 2022 here's everything you need
to know about the new islanders their
instagram handles ages jobs and what
they actually look like in real life so
what we've done now is we've entered a
world where the hyper real has become
more real than reality so photos from
instagram which is a social media
platform
known for enhanced and airbrushed images
is being used as the benchmark against
which everything else should be measured
instagram is what the cast actually look
like in real life despite the fact it's
taken by this huge army of of people
that are behind the uk's biggest reality
tv show they're doing them so dirty so i
think it's it was just really
interesting to me that kind of the bar
stool has been turned upside down that
people are so used to spending time
online with others that they see the
online world as more accurate than the
physical one and the closer that we can
fit real life to a digital existence the
more comfortable people feel
yeah that's very interesting especially
because usually on instagram everything
is filtered and so orchestrated that
you're not really getting
the reality of the person but that's
what they see they're like look this is
what people really look like in real
life and somehow these photos and videos
remember they do this huge big
intro hi my name's jessica or i'm 19 and
a hairdresser from wigan or whatever
what like what do you what are you
trying to say you're trying to say that
somehow the instagram is more real
than the photos and the videos that have
been taken and that they should be
retrofitted to make people feel more
comfortable to better represent the real
them which comes from instagram it just
seemed so backward it's like the most
blatant
social media life
representation that i think i've ever
seen and this is the lead up to love
island which is in the uk is kind of
like a
uh
i guess a national ritual now i did the
first season i was the first person
through the doors of season one which is
why i know that the process and the army
of hair and makeup people that go on
behind it um but it does make me feel a
little bit better because i got did
quite dirty by my stylist as well but
i don't know i i didn't ever think that
it was unrepresentative i just thought
that i got put in a
shitty pair of swim shots
yeah i mean whoever is working on that
end is deciding what i guess everybody
should look like
i think that happens with dating too we
put out what we should look like and
then we meet the person in real life and
it's like we get a much accurate
picture of them
yeah
being more accurate i think sets you up
for more success
yeah well i mean if you pitch yourself
we were talking about this before that
um i would love to see um people that
are in relationships that maybe met
online on tinder or whatever
go back and look at their profile the
profile of their partner when they first
met and play a game where you said okay
just how accurate was this person when
they were trying to show themselves
online you know was their
hinge or tinder profile accurately
representing them and based on what you
know now after five years of being
together and maybe marriaging kids or
whatever um
just how truthful was that and how
important is it is there a success
correlated between people that are
accurate and realistic with the way that
they portray themselves on online dating
and success long-term in relationships
or can you kind of fake it until you
make it and claim that you're
six foot five and
whatever you want to be in the world and
then once you've got people through the
door sort of change that around i
thought that'd be a really interesting
thing to do
i happen to think it the more you put
accurate pictures of yourself online
when you're dating then when you meet
the person
and they see how amazing you are in
person it only adds to your
success rather than someone being
disappointed because you misrepresented
yourself online well love island are
going to be disappointed with everything
that they do unfortunately it would seem
apparently everybody's going to be
misrepresented but
like i say it's a people get super
passionate there's an entire subculture
online now of people doing twitter
threads comparing the photos from the
press tour
media team with people's actual
instagrams and again i can't believe how
how they've done them dirty what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace